my guest this week is Kelly Carlin
daughter of the legendary comedian
George Carlin Kelly is an author and a
speaker whose work connects many of the
dots her father's life was all about
I've known Kelly for about four years
now after connecting with her on Twitter
because of how much I admired her dad we
become great friends Kelly has welcomed
me into her world and the comedy
community she's part of here in LA I
thought Kelly would be the perfect guest
this week not only because of her new
book about growing up as a Carlin but
also because of all the issues her
father's comedy was about that have
become central themes of what we do here
on this show George Carlin was a
relentless defender of free speech using
words and language to push the limits of
what society found acceptable at the
time he railed against political
correctness like no other comic before
or anybody since he dissected the
absurdities of life that ultimately
bring us together rather than rip us
apart I can't tell you how often I'm
watching some campaign nonsense or some
ridiculous politically correct crusade
and think man I wish George Carlin was
still alive to tackle this not only do I
want you to see George Carlin in a new
way by sitting down with Kelly but i
also want to use our chat as a living
breathing example of something else
that's going on here as I mentioned
Kelly and I met on Twitter all I was to
her was another person tweeting at her
in 140 characters who had some
connection to her father like millions
of other people but through social media
we met we became friends and now we
share so much of our lives and our
passions together to me that's what's so
cool about what's happening here with
you guys the reaction to what we're
doing has gotten to a whole new level
I've been getting emails from literally
all over the world from Denmark to Saudi
Arabia to Mexico we're connecting
because of the same idea is that George
believed in which I believe in and which
you believe in by the way that doesn't
mean that we agree on everything
actually in almost every email I get
that's heaping praise on me you guys
manage to tell me something that we
disagree on I love that that's what this
is all about and it's precisely what the
far right and the regressive left fear
if the rest of us can wake up and
realize that we can come together
despite differences then they can't
control us it's really as simple as that
the authoritarians that exists on both
sides want control and the best way to
do that is to keep everyone hating on
each other all the time
for all the things that Milo you napolis
and I disagreed on this is one spot we
had total agreement the rise of the
cultural libertarians is here and it
contains people from all over the
cultural map from Chris Rock to Bill
Maher from maajid nawaz to sam Harris if
George Carlin was still around I think
he would fit right in there but would
have also been sure to make fun of any
group that would have accepted him as
part of it the point of all this is that
every week actually every day that I've
been doing this show I see this movement
getting stronger you guys are not only
connecting with me but with each other
and now when I see the usual regressive
spout off their nonsense there's an army
of people calling them out on it that is
literally as important as anything that
I do George Carlin's most famous routine
was the seven dirty words you can't say
on TV we live in a time that's getting
dangerously close to the several dirty
ideas that you can't challenge publicly
let's honor the Trailblazers before us
like George Carlin by relentlessly
challenging and ruthlessly mocking those
who would attempt to silence us
you